this is one of the last known locations
of the Galaxy leader as it made its way
through the Red Sea Yemen's houy Rebels
say they've seized the cargo vessel and
it's now at a Yemen Port they've stated
that all Israeli linked vessels are at
risk the yemeni Armed Forces reiterate
their warning to All Ships affiliated
with the Israeli enemy or those dealing
with it that they will become legitimate
targets for the Armed
Forces Hamas has thanked the houth for
the hijacking and for support in its
fight against
Israel this is a welcome step from the
Yony forces and I believe that the size
of the Zionist crime committed in Gaza
makes every loyalist eager to defend and
support the Palestinian people with all
he can for Israel this incident is part
of a Iranian orchestrated Continuum of
conflict taking in Hamas in the occupied
Palestinian territories Hezbollah in
Lebanon and the houthis in Yemen all
groups that Israel sees as proxies to a
greater or lesser extent of tan prime
minister Benjamin netanyahu's office
says this is another Act of Iranian
terrorism which expresses a Leap Forward
in Iran's aggression against the
citizens of the Free World and creates
International implications regarding the
security of global shipping lanes Iran
has denied it had anything to do with
the hijacking but Israeli security
are worried about its implications for
international shipping this is uh
intended to open a new front in addition
to Lebanon in order to divert attention
from Gaza or divert resources but um it
is not in the H interest also the
American fifth Fleet is operating there
they have a base in Somali too um so uh
it's in everyone's uh interest to calm
down in the Red Sea the reverberation
from hamas's attacks of October the 7th
and Israel's war on Gaza are being felt
throughout the region Rory Chalin Al
jazer occupied East Jerusalem